the best way to play horseshoes and
Rihanna's but sings a song it's episode
36 of IMG mankind has come a long way
but this concept for an alarm clock that
slowly shreds money until you wake up
and stop it is genius less genius is
this guy
kid kid shark kid and here's a cat with
cat shaped fur enjoy your summer with a
death star melon and once cold weather
arrives wear some mittens that have a
second pair of mittens built into them
so you can hold your child's hand and
give them gloves is this the front or
the side of a man and this blurry face
is both one face and two faces kissing
can you see both but now a famous
psychology experiment which of these
shapes is called Bobo and which is
called Kiki it turns out that because
our brains so naturally assign abstract
concepts to sounds around the world no
matter what language or culture people
come from nearly 98% call this one Kiki
and that one
Bobo however this is not how to use a
doorknob so let's do triplets mariachi
band fried chicken
bathtub man monkey parrot and now let's
enjoy classic cartoon heroes as pinup
girls
[Music]
this cat can be made out of this cat by
doing this and this goose is wearing
sandals people don't always listen to
rules and they can't always see the
hidden dog once you find him make a
koopa and jump read it brought us Bruce
Willis loving Bruce Willis but here's a
kid who is forever alone here's a
photographer oh the only thing worse is
send email to this address
Clippy is just as annoying in real life
but tattoo and your Facebook friends
onto your real life arm is awesome on
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming David
showed us a panda dog and Nicolas
suggested a twisted e equals mc-squared
that's more emo a different guy named
david displayed some LEGO creations he's
selling on eBay this toilet is creative
but these are even scarier today's
episode of IMG was very special because
right now I am in London in fact check
this out that bathtub that is now a
table used to belong and was used by
Douglas Adams a couple days ago I was in
Dublin and terminal two at the Dublin
Airport is very important let me show
you what it looks like when you drive in
now if you think of it in a certain way
it can kind of remind you of being born
except in Reverse think about that for a
second subscribe to Vsauce for more and
as always thanks for watching
you
[Music]